your mother has raised you she would
have preferred to have two chickens
that is a problem what's she gonna do
oh my god the moral of the story
don't bring a purse to a fist fight
don't bring a woman to a man fight
you have lost
[Music]
okay so there wasn't a seat for her on
the plane
okay right now we're dealing with a huge
issue airline wise where a lot of people
are having their flights canceled uh
airlines are a hot mess with
cancellations delays and baggage losses
and so i could imagine that if i got on
a plane and then you told me there's no
seat for me because you oversold and i
gotta be somewhere i would be livid
yes
so is she mad i could understand why she
may she losing her [ __ ] because
depending on what she needs to get to
they were so greedy they [ __ ] her over
and sometimes i don't know his
disposition
sometimes airline people just don't look
like they give [ __ ] sometimes
sometimes
i mean it's not their fault they're not
the front pers it's not your fault their
fault so i understand why they don't
want to give a [ __ ] but god damn you
then [ __ ] over a person's whole wii
because if i pay for airbnbs if i pay
for other stuff other people are meeting
me there and we've all taken time off oh
that can cost a lot of money when you
[ __ ] me over well there are two things
okay go for it customers really take
they really
are entitled to talking to you all sorts
of ways right right and on the other
side
people that work in that industry are so
fed up because they're underpaid and
everything and stuff and they're dealing
with a whole bunch of problem with
people and on top of the company don't
really give a [ __ ] they don't give a
[ __ ] about their employees if you take
any airlines like eric canada i know for
a fact you don't care about your
employees i know you don't okay so it
can get people aggravated that's
definitely aggravated you know i mean
so
so on both sides you got a situation
where both people are right there
aggravated from the from the start the
customers are aggravated we don't like
to fly because your service is garbage
it's not a
specific airline airlines in general
your your service is garbage no matter
how much you trust and it's not even the
the people's fault you're often times
not giving the tools they cut back just
in order for them to to to save money
but you don't have the tools in order to
give a pristine service but you're tied
you're overworked underpaid i get that
so you have a situation where both
people are fed up and this what happens
you're in my personal space stay out of
my personal space
she's touching me she's trusting me
okay
again again she got super brave she got
super brave and hit him right when did
she do that hold on hold on when the guy
arrived of course and i'ma tell you from
the side of the company
the guy working for spirit
could have left a long ass time ago yup
he could have left
and i understand she should have never
hit him and then you got brave when the
man [ __ ] you lady you you you trash for
that
i don't you don't like when people no
you that's trash behavior not the whole
person but that behavior is right the
minute the older hey you got you got you
got to hit him i mean she
that's [ __ ] but you might do and that's
the reason why if you look on the side
of a company we think about the
escalation of a situation sure you could
have left a whole last time ago
same behavior as some police officers
that stayed in your face and want you to
react and the minute you pop off they
cuff your ass they want you to react
because they can react because they the
police they will win and they got the
law on their side
you could have left a long ass time ago
the minute you said don't go in my
personal face you cannot say get out my
personal space and advance on a
[ __ ] you know how that looks
[ __ ] sus my dude
so both of y'all wrong i'm sorry that's
like woman who'll be slapping dude did
you put your hands on me did you put
your hands up
now now no
all things said yeah now that she's put
her hands on him
i don't care what happens i don't know
what's going to happen
always from a professional standpoint
i agree everything you said is perfect
right can't do that on job no you put my
your hands on me but you smacked him
no i got time today hey if y'all didn't
know i haven't preached preacher proper
feminist equality for all equal rights
equal lefts
an equal knees [ __ ]
don't forget the knees
the minute you now all bets are off
back in ethiopia there are times when we
are going to cross the border
do you know sometimes the security they
go say no you are going to wait you're
going to wait the entire day until the
uh
commander is going to come back because
you are going to search our papers
everything you have to sleep in the car
do you think we can just get up there
and slap somebody no do you want to know
why
because he's going to come back he's
going to have a clashing call you're
going to have the ak-47
yes punching is great bullets are better
so we have made the decision executive
to say no no no we are not going to
engage in violence like this this is a
big deal so me when i come to canada and
i see women it's just smart
like like they are preparing bread like
they are going to season
pepper me i have a problem i say you are
just going to be comfortable like this
eh our friend you are a problem hey i
see with the red shoes i see with the
red shoes that means you are a problem
that means in the back of your car you
have a secret ak-47 i'm quite certain
they must
they must you do not mean to tell me
these women have come to a gunfight and
they have come on armed
because that's what that is what a woman
is doing she is physically a smaller
more weak
and she has made the decision to come to
a man who is bigger who basically he has
like a gun
and shall decide to engage in violence
that means there is a secret
in the back of her purse there is a
clashing
eh and if there isn't you are quite
stupid so yeah you're dumb you're an
idiot
your mother has raised you she would
have preferred to have two chickens
that is a problem
you have decided to engage in violence
with somebody that raised you she would
prefer to have to take no no no
because because you have to understand
you have decided you have made the
decision
to engage in violence when you are
weaker
what kind of individual decides today i
want to lose a fight
who leaves their home and says i hope to
get punched harder than i punch them
not me
have you seen my face i am quite ugly as
it is i don't want to make it worse
i don't do it don't do it don't do it if
you're watching at home please my
friends a papaya don't do it don't do it
well because so many are watching you
are ugly already you have decided i wish
plastic surgery make me uglier
for what reason hey do you want a nose
to be crooked like this no you don't
look like kylie jenner you look like
jenna kagler
who is this we don't want to know she
doesn't have instagram that's going to
be you don't do it basically don't eat
the moral of the story don't bring a
purse to a fist fight don't bring a
woman to a man fight
she can't put my hands on me
you slapped him
remember when we
you slapped him in his face and you see
the react you could play that [ __ ] back
you see the minute he got slapped he
lost his [ __ ] just remember what we said
about slapping preach if you get punched
what you gonna do it's a fight and if
you get slapped somebody's gotta die
let's find out if she's a punch
i could deal it with now or later hey
once i get off work i got all your
information baby ding dong that's a fair
one you could do that yeah if you slap
me no
i don't even know
yo shout out to this guy you know what
that looked like you know that yeah that
looked like a football joke
i just saw aaron donald at the airport
hey bro if you're looking for a new
career the dallas cowboys are always
hiring
my man and here he's not going off that
part tackle her yeah
even the dude realize like man listen i
can't stop the mvp of the league
the pushing was good the knees was there
turn that [ __ ] back
that that's yeah that's what happens
when the starter goes to get into
practice hey flag on the plate flag on
the plane
okay
i get that now if we say we stay on the
same level
i'm in your face when your face we both
wrong i don't move you don't move then
then you you come
it's like when you have an argument with
a white person okay and you just arguing
with that person and everything is cool
and then that person is losing their
argument and they completely look at you
like
the minute
you cross the line there was a line we
were just talking about you know what we
were we were just talking about
our points and everything we're just
discussing and stuff you went racial
it's a wrap if we're discussing you go
physical
it's a wrap men are women i don't care
i don't care
you got comfortable flapping slapping a
[ __ ] because you thought you
would not get here but guess what
guess what baby some [ __ ]
sometimes
keep your hands to yourself people damn
you don't know what kind of day people
are having you think you're gonna be
saved nah he's 100 you're gonna catch
one eventually
keep your hands to yourself don't
nobody
don't ensue violent things are gonna
happen there's some people that got you
don't know what lives they have what
time they got what day they had how much
football training
you do not know tell them keep all that
[ __ ] don't don't that's that's foul
ladies
you feel very comfortable sometimes
slapping a [ __ ] that they do
okay you feel very comfortable being
physical with listen
hey
hey
if you
if we walking down the street
okay and you with me
and you do some outlandish [ __ ] like
that okay and you get decked in the
mouth oh what happens and you did some
outlandish [ __ ] i don't care oh no
to me it's just some [ __ ] that happened
don't expect me to lift a finger i'ma
look at the [ __ ] and you're
gonna be like what you want something to
no no you served her she was outlandish
doesn't do it don't don't do it don't do
this
don't do it man i got flashbacks
and that goes for men too yes men are
just more used to violence but that goes
for men let me say you want to do if
you're a dude if you're a dude
don't instigate don't start don't start
nothing there won't be nothing let me
say this men understand that much better
which is why we don't casually put our
hands if a man put his hands and you
smack him back he won't stand there
looking surprised
right oh it's a square up it's because
you know it's a square there's literally
never been a time that's where a fight
happened between me and the guy and i
didn't know what was going to happen oh
and that's why and that's why oh ben put
his hands on me
we're going at it he's never been like
oh you're going to hit me when there's a
conversation with two guys we know
remember remember what they do sometimes
they stand like that and they just put
each other in the chest yeah cause they
know that the man what is that this
happens yes they we go like this yo what
you're gonna do what you're gonna do and
they just bump chest and their hands are
way back because they know the minute
the minute their hands their hands cross
that line yeah i don't i no longer see
it's a threat
women are the only ones i know who can
initiate violence
get smacked and then act shocked yeah
like they just didn't do the very
[ __ ] thing that happened to them yes
you get what i'm trying to say what
you're gonna do
oh my god that happens all the time all
the time all the time it's like calling
someone stupid then you get called done
done you'd be like
how are you insulting me
come on man wake up wake up stop that
again i understand i sympathize because
i understand how [ __ ] frustrated this
airline situation is but taking it on
the person at the front desk isn't going
to make your situation better because
they're not the reason why you in this
[ __ ] up place
so it's misplaced anger i understand it
but you got to know where to direct it
that's why i have a i have to think like
a mental effort like let's say when i'm
dealing with issues with my credit card
company or with an airline i have to
make a mental effort to understand the
person right in front of me isn't the
person who caused my problem okay
but
you know customer service people you
guys also got to understand you
represent a company so you're going to
also deal with a bit of frustration from
people oh yeah all right so
let us know what you guys think
don't do it don't do it
don't have a fire you know what has
taught us
safe defense
for what reason got to wait for the
police
giving me a gun
if you are going to put your hands on
him we have decided it is a fight to the
death
don't do it